So far, we have been talking about
rearrangements in unichromosomal genomes.
But of course, mammalian genomes are multi
chromosome, and we now want to look at
more complex scenarios of rearrangements
in multi chromosomal genomes.
You may be surprised that we are moving to
seemingly
more difficult case without even a clue on
how we would
address a simpler case of sorting
by reversal
so in the case of a unichromosomal genome.
But as you will see it turns out that
rearrangements
of multi chromosomal genomes are actually
counter-intuitively, a simple problem.
We'll start from some example of
rearrangements in
human genomes, and we'll talk about
Philadelphia chromosome.
So these are normal
chromosome 9 and 22 in human,
and they have genes called
abl and bcr located at these chromosomes.
Now, consider a break in two places on
each of these chromosomes that
separate each chromosome into two.
This is not unlike the two breaks that
reversals do, but in this case these
two breaks are applied to different
chromosomes.
And then afterwards consider gluing the
segments in
a new order resulting in new chimeric
chromosomes.
As a result something happen, genes abl
and bcr that were located at different
chromosomes in normal human genomes are
now located at the same chromosome
next to each other.
And as a result it destroys the regulation
of these genes and leads to a disease
called Chronic Myeloid Leukemia or CML.
It's actually this oncogenic fusion gene is
a hallmark of CML.
So, from a computational perspective
the operation that I just showed you is
called "translocation"
and it's exchange segments of different
chromosomes between each other.
And, thousands of different
rearrangements, and
many translocations, are known for
different tumors.
Knowledge about these rearrangements is
very important for studies of cancer.
In particular the
abl bcr fusion genes in CML
since biologists knew how it looks like,
it enable development of a very
efficient cancer drug called Glivec.
And so far I showed you an example of when
a single rearrangement leads to a disease.
In reality, for many tumors, the situation is
more complex.
Here I showed you an image resulting from
a technique called
chromosome painting and as a result of
this chromosome painting, every
chromosome in a normal
cell should be painted by
a single color.
There is a unique color for every normal
human chromosome.
However, if you start chromosome painting
on a human genome, and in this case there's
this MCF7, human
breast cancer cell line that you see a
very colorful pictures.
This colorful picture illustrates that
hardly
any chromosome remain intact in MCF7.
Since every chromosome
consists of different pieces, sometimes
two, three, even four
pieces, of different human chromosomes
combined together.
And it's a very question to figure out what
sequence of rearrangement
has produced the MCF7 Tumor Genes.
And in the next section we will look
at operation on multichromosomal genomes
that includes
not only translocations, but also fusions
and fissions.
For example, fusion simply combine to
chromosomes and glues
them together and fusion breaks a
chromosome into two.
For example, humans have 23 chromosomes,
but chimpanzee, orangutan
and gorilla have 24
chromosomes because a few million years
ago two
chromosomes in a human chimpanzee
ancestors were fused together into a
single chromosome
in human.
And in the next section, we will look at
the algorithmic problem that is called the
2-Break Distance
to address their question of how
to find rearrangements in
multichromosomal genomes.